OKAY, YOU HOPE ALL RIGHT WE
KICK THINGS OFF.
WITH A VERY IMPORTANT NOW A
THROW BACK THURSDAY, SO. THEY
LOVE IS A FRIEND THAT SHOULD
AND HAD DO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FESTIVAL, THE LOVERS AND
FRIENDS FESTIVAL.
WHICH WILL FEATURE
PERFORMANCES FROM ICONIC
ARTISTS INCLUDING FROM
MIDMORNING HILL CR LUDACRIS
JOE DUCEY AND MANY MORE 22 BUT
YOU CAN ALREADY GET A TICKET
THEY'RE SPECIAL PRESALE
THEY'LL BE HAVING.
BE EASIER TO MAKE A FLYER
WITH WITH WHO'S NOT GOING TO
BE THERE THERE ARE BE
LISTEN I TOLD MY SON MY
FRIENDS CAN WE JUST ALL
CARPOOL IN A BIG YELLOW SCHOOL
BUS AND JUST TO REALLY TAKE
YOU BACK TO HIGH SCHOOL FOR
THIS ONE HOW ABOUT ONE OF MY
FAVORITES ON NELLIE KNOW LIKE
THE GUYS DOWN AND GET TO THE